ah
y bueno quiero empezar contándoles un
poco sobre cómo inicia yo en mi camino
de emprendedor y me gustaría dejar una
idea central que es
principalmente a todas estas historias
quiero conectarlas a la paciencia y
bueno nosotros empezamos ya hace casi
seis años como un proyecto estudiantil
un proyecto universitario en el cual
tuvimos la como mucha curiosidad en ese
momento de querer aprender sobre la
tecnología del concreto queríamos
aprender sobre la construcción y
obviamente encontrar un lugar en donde
los curiosos pues podríamos encontrarnos
y en ese momento el en la universidad se
abrió un capítulo como estudiantil donde
habían actividades extracurriculares y
nosotros podíamos ser partícipes de ello
y así fue como inició esto tratando de
aprender concreto y siendo curiosos
en ese momento nosotros tuvimos la
oportunidad de representar a nuestra
universidad a nivel estatal presentando
un cilindro de concreto que se habían
dos categorías no una donde los digamos
que presionaba el concreto la compresión
y el que mas resistiera era el que
ganaban y eso estaba padrísimo porque
bueno en concreto explota cuando los
sometes a altas presiones y la otra es
que tenías que darle una resistencia
objetivo que generalmente es como lo más
complicado porque pues tienes que hacer
que el cilindro truene el concreto
reviente a la a una carga específica no
y eso es muy complicado y en aquel
momento pues igual sin mucha experiencia
pero eso sí con muchas ganas con mucho
ánimo pues logramos obtener muy buenos
lugares en aquel momento entonces desde
ahí se me quedó la espinita como esa
adrenalina de de probar lo que sabes
como eso que te gusta y poner la prueba
y eso creo que en aquel momento a todos
nuestros compañeros nos llenaba como de
alegría y emoción y pues de ganas de
seguir adelante
entonces en aquel momento
seguimos en ese camino participando
entrando a clases
estando en diferentes concursos probando
obviamente todo lo que tenía que ver con
el concreto entonces ya de entrada yo
sabía que era algo que me apasionaba la
industria de la construcción y hubo un
momento en el que tuvimos la oportunidad
también de representar a la universidad
pero ya no a nivel estatal sino que esté
a nivel internacional y fue la primera
vez que en mi equipo y yo salíamos al
extranjero no entonces
creo que siempre algo que hemos tenido
en duda es probarnos a nosotros mismos
qué tan lejos podemos llegar y en aquel
momento teníamos muchas dudas porque era
la primera vez que salíamos
era un concurso internacional contra
otras universidades de otros países y
este y obviamente pues los nervios no de
de cargar con una
responsabilidad nuestra de representar a
nuestra universidad a nuestra familia
que fueron quienes nos apoyaron a
nuestros amigos y en aquel momento
afortunadamente
después de mucho trabajo se obtuvo un
segundo lugar y cuando regresamos de la
ciudad de méxico pues todo estábamos
bien emocionados y recuerdo que la
maestra nos preguntó no está maestra nos
ayudó muchísimo porque nos ayudó
comprando un boleto para para irnos a
eeuu un boleto de avión y este y nos
preguntó oigan pues está muy padre qué
bueno que regresaron me da muchísima
alegría que hayan obtenido un buen lugar
y sobre todo que hayan representado a la
universidad y nos preguntó qué queríamos
hacer y en ese momento creo que como
todo estudiante pues decíamos si hay
mucha investigación podríamos poner todo
eso en un papel y convertirlo en una
tesis
y pues ya no es titular pero en realidad
la maestra nos dijo oye por qué no vas a
la biblioteca y revisa todas las tesis
que hay en la en la biblioteca de a lo
mejor algunos compañeros maestros
incluso y revisa que todas tienen polvo
sea en realidad mucha gente hace tesis y
qué bueno pero pues ustedes con lo que
tienen deberían de hacer algo más no
está bien que quieran hacer una tesis
pero busquen una utilidad a eso que
ustedes estaban haciendo en aquel
momento se hizo un concretó permeable
que permitía pasar el agua a los mantos
acuíferos y obviamente la idea principal
era que nosotros íbamos a mejorar el
tema de rendimiento en la ciudad de
méxico- temas muy importantes no como
como es el la filtración de agua los
mantos acuíferos
y obviamente disminuir los
encharcamientos en las ciudades porque
hoy en día tenemos pavimento
normal no sé a pavimentos que no son
permeables y generalmente el agua de
lluvia se va a una alcantarilla y pues
no se trata o sea se junta con las aguas
grises con las aguas negras y pues al
final de cuentas no no le damos utilidad
y entonces ahí surgió esa espinita
porque bueno la un dato bien interesante
es que el concreto es una de las
industrias que más contamina luego que
también es una de los materiales más
utilizados después del agua se dice que
es el segundo material y bueno eso es
verdad no a cualquier lado donde miremos
hay concreto nuestras casas son concreto
aquí atrás hacemos concreto entonces
éste obviamente para nosotros era una
oportunidad porque sabíamos de entrada
que ya era algo que todo el mundo
ocupaba pero también sabíamos que había
un problema y es el tema ambiental y era
algo que a nosotros nos apasionaba
teníamos que buscar y y este y teníamos
el impulso de querer cambiar al mundo y
así inició
nuestro emprendimiento yo les quería
hablar de la paciencia porque eso fue
hace seis años cuando nosotros estábamos
en la universidad y creo que
algo que nos pasa a nosotros cuando
somos jóvenes es que tenemos mucha
desesperación recién estaba escuchando
una
plática sobre la crisis de los 40 y yo
digo que también los jóvenes tenemos la
crisis de los lentes en las en las que
nosotros estamos pensando en que va a
ser de nuestra vida y pues en realidad
prácticamente es lo que nosotros
queramos no les platico esto porque así
inició este proyecto
y una vez que ya hablamos sobre sobre
este sobre los inicios me gustaría
platicarles tres momentos distintos
en el explicamos como en el desarrollo
de mi emprendimiento que que hoy por hoy
hacemos vivienda y nos dedicamos a la
industria del concreto este la primera
es que cuando esto había iniciado
obviamente no sabes nada de plan de
negocios no sabes nada de
de esa facturación es no sabes nada de
constituir empresas y es que no son
temas propios de tu formación académica
obviamente si estudias test a lo mejor
algo que tenga que ver con lo fiscal
pues ya sabéis ya sabrías cómo realizar
una factura pero si estás estudiando
ingeniería o cualquier otra carrera será
difícil no que que supieras sobre temas
de empresas o sobre temas de negocios y
eso para nosotros era muy frustrante
porque sabíamos que queríamos hacer algo
pero en realidad no no teníamos en ese
momento las herramientas adecuadas
para poder llevarlo a cabo teníamos
mucho impulso muchas ganas y era muy
difícil no y recuerdo que en uno de los
concursos entramos a un concurso de
digamos como de pequeñas startups donde
queríamos buscar financiamiento entonces
en aquel momento pues no había dinero
entonces teníamos que buscar una fuente
de buscamos un inversionista y éste y
los concursos pues era una excelente
manera de buscarlo y en estos concursos
pues nunca ganamos participamos más de
tres o cuatro veces siempre quedamos en
semifinales siempre
llegamos a muy buenos lugares pero nunca
llegamos a ese momento que todo
emprendedor busca que es encontrar a un
inversionista o ganar un concurso que
capitalice tu empresa y ganes ese ese
capital que dices necesitar para
emprender y eso es muy frustrante porque
pones todo tu corazón con este empeño
pones todas tus ganas y al final
terminas quizá en ese momento
decepcionado porque estás con la emoción
y con la adrenalina al cien pero en
realidad no te das cuenta que estás
aprendiendo entonces ese es uno de los
momentos para mí como más complicados
porque por más que participaba por más
que buscaba por más que le echamos ganas
en realidad no lo grabamos nosotros que
cumplir nuestra meta que era pues echar
andar esto con ese capital semilla
entonces para mí la gran lección es que
de tantas veces que le intentamos
de tantas veces que nos dijeron que no
hay de tantas puertas que nos cerraban
pues aprendimos una manera de como este
de cómo abrir puertas encontramos una
nueva manera de levantarnos una nueva
manera de participar y eso de alguna
manera ya estaba abonando a hablar lo
que hoy
nuestra experiencia nos ha funcionado
para el funcionamiento de nuestra
empresa y para esto creo que la una de
las principales habilidades o virtudes
que debe tener el emprendedor debe ser
la paciencia no tener muy claro que no
todo va a salir a la primera entonces
pues ese es el primer momento que les
quería contar sobre sobre nosotros el
segundo después de tantas puertas
abiertas de más bien de tantas puertas
cerradas de tantas emociones de tal vez
de que las cosas no salían
hubo un momento en el que nos invitaron
a participar en el programa ser tank y
nosotros participamos afortunadamente
nos fue muy bien pero creo que ahí es
donde empieza uno de los momentos
también más estresantes de mi vida
porque para empezar era la primera vez
que nosotros nos presentábamos ante
inversionistas y como los tiburones y
eso era para mí también y para mi equipo
pues una una nueva experiencia y creo
que algo que siempre tuvimos en mente
era
como
lo hicimos bien pero no sabemos qué va a
pasar después entonces ahí ahí en ese
momento antes de que pudiéramos empezar
a trabajar de manera
y digamos ya al 100% con los tiburones
pasó mucho tiempo y todo ese tiempo de
espera en lo que se podía concretar una
inversión en lo que se podría concretar
lo que era una posible colaboración pues
pasó mucho tiempo hubo mucha inversión
de nuestra parte y mucho desgaste
anímico porque pues obviamente tienes
que adaptarte a una nueva forma de
trabajo tienes que aceptar la entrada de
nuevos socios a tu empresa y tienes que
aceptar que no todo
es como tú lo planeas sino que
generalmente debes de adaptarte a cómo
trabajan las demás personas y eso es
algo muy importante para el emprendedor
debes de saber adaptarse a los cambios
demasiado rápido y en ello debes de
aprender al máximo no
hay momentos en los que debes de tomar
decisiones también muy rápidas pero las
decisiones rápidas las debes de tomar de
la mejor manera y con la mayor
información posible y entre todo ello yo
también en globo que la paciencia sigue
siendo una de las de las principales
virtudes no en aquel momento para que se
pudiera concretar una inversión tardó
aproximadamente un año en lo que
nosotros
más bien juntábamos nuestros nuestros
documentos nuestros planes de negocio
este y obviamente pues nos adaptamos a
los tiempos de los inversionistas
entonces eso es algo también que quería
contar que era uno de cómo de los
momentos pues también más más
complicados y el último tiene que ver
con con todo el proceso nosotros
aprendimos a valorar cada momento de
cada proceso en nuestra empresa se fundó
con una con tres pilares que era el
medio ambiente
la sociedad y la calidad y en ese
digamos como en ese inicio nosotros nos
pusimos una meta y la meta era que nos
queríamos convertir en la herramienta
que le pueda funcionar a cualquier
persona queríamos ser la plataforma de
desarrollo en materia de construcción y
queríamos ser esa herramienta que se
ponía a disponibilidad de nuestros
usuarios a disposición de todo aquel que
construía no
teníamos esa misión muy clara y en aquel
momento no teníamos o no se nos había
pasado por la mente que en todos
aquellos momentos en los que nosotros
queríamos
y hacer las cosas si no funcionaban y
que eso en algún momento te pega de
manera anímica y generalmente
te dan ganas de renunciar porque dices
oye no está funcionando las cosas no van
bien ya fui muy paciente creo que lo que
siempre te reconforta o más bien lo que
te mantiene de pie es ese momento en el
que tú decidiste un darte como como
emprendedor o decidiste fijar un
propósito sobre lo que querías hacer en
el futuro también debemos de saber
identificar hasta qué momento ser
pacientes porque hay veces en las que
las cosas por más que le busquemos
quizás no vayan a funcionar y nosotros
sabemos o más bien debemos saber si es
el momento ideal para decir ya no puedo
y se vale no
no es echarse para atrás sino decir he
intentado de todo y quizá este no es la
mejor forma y vamos a buscar hacer algo
nuevo entonces también tengamos esa
apertura a nosotros saber identificar
hasta cuándo ser pacientes y obviamente
a saber reinventarnos de mi parte ese es
algo que les quería compartir y bueno
los dejo con esta vista que a mí me
inspira muchísimo es una de las de las
bloqueras donde construimos sueños donde
construimos esperanzas y donde brindamos
oportunidades muchísimas gracias